[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Rachel Cruz this is the Ramsey show it
is not smart money happy hour which is
another show that we co-host together
but we going to bring that kind of
energy and fun today we hope so it's
going to be a fun show George we're
already bringing it with our outfits
we're very brightly colored today bright
yellow bright orange so if you're
watching on YouTube I apologize dim your
screens my shirt is like get some
sunglasses but it's fun it's it's what
makes you so joyful and ever vescent
Rachel bright well hey give us a call
we'll talk about your life and your
money atle
5225 Jeff joins us in Toronto Canada
Jeff what's going on
hi thanks for your call guys how you
doing doing well how are you okay um
just wanted to talk to you today um
we're concerned that we probably look
better than we are uh we've got no
student debt no credit card debt no
other debts per se other than the
morgage but the mortgage is
625 um and advertised over 28 more years
and we're 49 so we've obviously sort of
refinanced things into the mortgage a
couple too many times
and we're on a variable mortgage we
can't help that right now but so I guess
I'm I'm wondering how should we should
we look at our situation more like we
have say 100 grand left in Mortgage Debt
but we've maybe got a half a mill in
debt we should really tackle but this
whole thing is in one
mortgage yes okay what's your household
income 210 Canadian okay and what is the
mortgage payment every
month uh because the variable rate we're
up to 6.2% now so it's gone up up to
about just under 4,000 wow and what's
your take-home
pay uh take-home on that is about uh
about
11 months
okay all right I mean it's a that's a
hefty mortgage even with your gr income
um I don't know that it's a fire right
now you don't have any other debt right
no everything else is clean so how much
extra do you have as you kind of create
a budget how much extra do you have to
throw at the mortgage every single month
right now now well now that it's gone up
like that and and saving for General
Affairs and the four kids very little
we're going to try and we're just trying
to rebalance and bring it down to the
Bare Bones um this week okay so the
other 7,000 is just disappearing into
expenses even no debt well yeah yeah
it's it's you know yeah are you
investing yeah sorry we do have
retirement we got um we get a match at
work so I got to keep that going because
it's free money and um What's the total
your invest out of your household
income are on on mine it's 4% to get a m
6% to get a match and my wife's is 4% so
it's kind of like an average of 5%
total okay man I'm still wondering where
all the leftover money is
going I thought you were GNA say we're
investing no gr is about 2300 um I mean
all the other insurances and things
um yeah we're going to cut it down try
and and cut it back
but okay well to your original question
there's no way to really split this debt
up if it's in one giant mortgage we're
just going to attack it you would be
what we call baby step six if you have a
fully funded emergency fund do you guys
have that money set aside in savings
three to six months of
expenses no okay how much do you have in
savings oh it's just kind of month to
month so very little because we just
throw that
at so you're straight up paycheck to
paycheck even making
210 that's correct okay yeah so Jee I
think that's probably one of your
biggest problems it feels like oh my
gosh we're on the edge because you kind
of are on the edge if you don't have
that saving so I do think that buffer of
six months put away is going to ease
some of this tension knowing that
there's cash there if something happens
does lower your stress because you know
yes you have the big mortgage but other
than that um you know you're you're
going to be able to breathe at night
when knowing that you have this
emergency fund so I think doing that's
going to relieve some of the stress and
then I think yeah you and your wife have
to kind of look at each other and just
be like all right this is our this is
our mortgage and we don't want to live
in s too deep of sacrifice for too long
right because then you just burn out of
steam if you're doing this for 10 years
but there needs to be enough years yeah
right so there needs to be enough though
to say yeah we're feeling this progress
um and again I know the real estate
market in Canada is just it's it's wacky
like I feel like it is here right now in
America too um but maybe you guys look
up in 3 to four years with things that
have changed and maybe you say like hey
maybe we would rather be out of debt
faster than to keep this mortgage and
maybe there's some Equity there and you
make a different decision with the house
if you want um right now may not be the
best time because I know rates and
everything are just it's nuts so uh like
George said it's not on fire but you
guys may
reconsider this mortgage depending on
how much it's still Weighing on you here
in a couple years sure if it if we if we
could rent the house and actually take
apartment that was cheaper I mean that
would create a cash flow benefit would
it if we could rent the place for about
the same price as the
mortgage yeah I mean in a perfect world
yes but then suddenly you have renters
and you still have a mortgage on it and
if the renter doesn't pay it's up to you
or if something breaks it's still up to
you I mean you're still owning a house I
think the the passive cash flow that
real estate provides is somewhat of a
lie it's not very passive it's very
reactive when you have Deb on it yeah
and especially when it's not paid off
but I I understand what you're saying
and yeah the numbers would make sense
but life usually doesn't work that
cleanly sadly I would work my way to
aggressively attack this mortgage and
that might mean we've got to get our
income up even though you're making
great money it might mean a season of
getting our income up getting our
expenses down if you looked at your
budget outside of your mortgage what
would you say are the biggest expenses
eating away that takon pay 2,300 is is
attributed to groceries $250 for dining
out um you utilities are say uh 400
electric and water how many kids do y
have gas four okay now I know Canadian
food prices are insane is 2,300 normal
over there that still feels really high
feels like yeah yeah we're pretty I
think we're pretty conservative but I
mean 2200 is everything you know
anything that the house consumes like
soaps and food and that sort of thing
household essentials all that yeah well
I think Jeff I think y'all's first goal
to feel some level of traction in piece
is that emergency fund I think that will
really do something to you guys a sense
of confidence that you're not living on
the edge cuz you won't be uh but that
would be the next that would be the that
would be the goal I tackle and then you
guys I would up some of your uh
retirement I would still be investing uh
more than what you guys are which I know
is going to give you even less to put at
the mortgage but then that's when I feel
like you guys could maybe re-evaluate
this house here in a year or two yeah
and the other thing I would do Jeff
which may hurt right now because it's
free money is pausing you're investing
until you have this emergency fund in
place that's right it's going to speed
that up number one but it'll also put a
fire under your belly to really get some
Financial Foundation under you and get
back to investing into the match and I
want you investing beyond that because
investing 4% you may not not have a
great retirement if that's all you do
for the rest of your life is Treading
Water yep oh for sure is there a way to
get Dave's list of of good mutual funds
the the long-term growth ones that he
talks about is that on the website well
we just split them up into four
categories we don't actually list any
specific funds because it's so dependent
on your investment vehicle which you
know firm you're and brokerage you're
investing with but we've got that
resource you can go to ramsy
solutions.com investing we've got a
whole investing Hub over there to help
you out with that but Jeff the real key
is there's no life hack here it's spend
less make more that's how you find that
margin and I know it's tough for our
Canadian listeners we feel for you guys
we've heard how insane it is over there
and uh we hope you get some some rest
bit soon from the chaos and craziness
this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
so George I don't know if you've been uh
having the Christmas discussion in your
house you got a new baby oh yeah uh so
I'm sure the first Christmas is going to
be it's going to be a special one Mia's
list is very long is it very long even
for a two-month-old she's just like her
mother she likes nice stuff I know and
we all do I know we've been talking to
our kids about it and always trying to
temper the expectations because that
contentment piece of teaching your kids
about this stuff is really important
because even people listening that are
on baby steps 2 and three you're getting
out of debt maybe you're saving up for
your emergency fund and it's going to be
a season of sacrifice and we're right in
the middle of the holidays and so that
means the holidays may look a little bit
different this year but the good news is
is that the gifts that you do give can
actually bring a lot of meaning so I
have a new kids book out it just
launched yesterday but I'm glad for what
I have and it does it talks all about
contentment that our stuff is okay but
you Journey along with these an these
little animals in the book to learn that
yes the more stuff you have does not
equal happiness and that contentment
piece is so crucial so make sure to
check that out another great option for
Christmas is George you can actually
pre-order George's book yeah Breaking
Free from broke you won't have it in
your hands uh this Christmas cuz it
launches in January very exciting uh but
you do such a great job tackling all the
myths so make sure to check that out at
ramseys solutions.com store and we have
a $12 sale going on for Christmas with
books like The Total Money Makeover baby
steps millionaires own your past change
your future uh love your life not theirs
a lot of the books that we've all
written are in that sale so make sure to
check that out because uh again this the
holidays are coming if you're going to
give a gift give a gift that actually
can help people and a lot of people find
the Ramsay plan and the baby steps
through a gift like oh my parents gave
me this book for Christmas or my friend
always had it and they lent it to me
gave me that book so you actually can
help spread this message of Hope when it
comes to our money so go to ramsy
solutions.com again/ store to check out
the $12 sale and what's cool is that
when you go to Ramsey solutions.com
you'll also see the Ramsey cash giveaway
we have going on that's $500 weekly
prizes a $5,000 grand prize you can
enter every day for your chance to win
we're just spreading the cheer in the
Ramsey solutions.com Merry Christmas
we're having a good time out here I'm
ready for it are you a Christmas person
yeah jump Thanksgiving I mean I know we
need to be grateful and stuff but I we
do kind of skip it we already have
Christmas up know Thanksgiving
decorations didn't make the cut this
year this weekend is our Christmas
decorating I can't wait I love it well
let's get to the calls Dustin is up next
in Charleston West Virginia what's going
on man hey guys thanks for taking my
call sure uh my wife and I we um we feel
that we make too much money to have to
you know each month worry that are we
putting enough in savings are we doing
the right thing with our money uh the
the interest rates have went back on
student loans uh we never had student
loans prior to co um and then postco you
know we probably weren't aggressive
enough paying off student loans with uh
interest off we probably did things with
with that money that we shouldn't have
done but see if maybe get a little
guidance on on how to tackle student
loans the best and are we maybe saving
enough uh and budgeting doing our budget
right okay yeah so how much student loan
debt do you guys have
uh she has 203,000 right now what's her
degree in uh anesthesia good okay and is
she how much is she making a year uh
combined we gross about 340 combined 340
okay so that's the student loans and
then any other debt how much do youall
owe on the cars uh we have two vehicles
and we have we also have two mortgages
we have a mortgage on our house and we
have the farm mortgage land mortgage
separate uh we rent
um an old mobile home on the farm that
covers that payment though okay so how
much and the the cars how much debt is
on them they're the one they're both a
little over 50,000 we owe one 50,000
each okay each yeah and then how much
and then any other Consumer Debt besides
the mortgage no we got mortgage Vehicles
student loans okay yeah I mean yeah and
I I mean I can I with these numbers I'm
like yeah you you owe as much as you
make a year so it is going to feel it's
going to feel tight is um do you guys
have any
savings uh we probably got 25 right now
we've just you know like I said we
weren't as responsible maybe as we
should have been when interest rates
were off the student loans we you know
spent a hundred, building a building a
new barn and right just doing whatever
doing whatever you want and now you now
every month you're committed to paying
that and you're thinking maybe I should
have been more responsible for the past
two years totally um so how much you
know how much should we think about
having in savings should we go a
different route on put less investing in
are you doing any investing right now um
we both max out uh for once okay okay
well that's going to free up a whole
bunch of money if we paused that
temporarily wouldn't it uh yeah but you
know should we do that or um if I had
$300,000 in Consumer Debt I would
definitely pause investing and here's
here's here's the reason cuz I know
you're going listen you guys are smart
people you're really good at math the
truth is making
$340,000 you guys should retire multi
multi multi multi-millionaires the
problem is there's a lot of people just
like you out there who don't retire with
that because they think well I'm just
going to hang on to this debt I'm not
I'm kind of comfortable we're just doing
a bunch of things at once but we're not
really making any progress so I think
you guys could crush this $300,000 in
debt in two years Le that would be uh
yeah that would be good it's just you
know so maybe Paul's what we're putting
in in retirement right now I would pause
all investing Dustin I would take your
$225,000 in savings and this is going to
make you feel real uncomfortable I would
take it down to 1,000 and I would throw
24,000 at at this debt and and if I were
you Dustin I'm like if it's $100,000 in
cars even though your income can
somewhat justify it we don't want it
more than half of your ual income so it
technically could justify it but almost
for the act of it I would just I would
get rid of them how much do you think
you could sell them for uh we could
probably clear 10 on each so You' make
20 grand
total yeah and use that you could buy a
used car for 10 grand to puts around in
for
now uh yeah and then you know like our
family uh my wife my wife's family I
guess you know they got used so you look
at that and my wife's they're always
working on those cars so what is how
much is the benefit um well a reliable
used car understand get rid of them yes
yeah they're so expensive nowadays
that's you know that's the I think
that's yeah you purchased a really
expensive car so you definitely know but
man you make 340 Grand buy
101,000 Honda Civic that's going to get
you guys around for a year I'm not
saying to live to to drive it for 10
years but be driving it for for a year
Dustin I'm like because what you guys
need there's there's a radical mindset
shift that that needs to happen for you
guys you've been doing your plan and
it's not working you make
$350,000 and I'm not trying to come down
on you too hard Dustin but there's
people listening right now that think
holy crap Rachel's being nice they're
angry at Dustin going oh my gosh I could
be doing so much with that income and
they're still feeling stress like this
is crazy so there needs to be a there
needs to be a radical shakeup Dustin you
guys you and your wife need to sit down
and feel like we we've do we've done
this all wrong like we have to do the
complete opposite of what we've been
doing which means selling stuff yes
buying a $112,000 car I mean doing
things that are so different than what
you guys have been doing tackling this
debt getting savings because if I told
you Dustin that gosh I mean we could sit
here and run the numbers but I'm like I
mean within within nine months if you
guys sold these cars and took your
income and paused investing through
everything at it you could look up by
next summer be almost deeptree and then
you guys could even look up and say oh
my gosh you know we could we're going to
have savings with that income having no
payments no payments how much you're
going to be able to save a 3 to six
months worth of expenses for an
emergency fund have that in place and
then start investing like your whole
financial World Destin could look
completely different in 18 months
completely different but that means you
guys are going have to do some really
different stuff and and I would
encourage you I want you to stay on the
line Dustin because I want to give you
Financial Peace University this is our
nine lesson course that I want you your
wife to sit down and go through this is
the basics of money and it is the
fastest way to build wealth from point A
to point B that's
sustainable and man I just I I'm so
hopeful and you guys live in Charleston
West Virginia you're not out in LA
California with insane yeah making that
kind of money yeah like you you guys can
do this like you have so much going for
you you have so much going for you but
you have to have the discipline you have
to look at money in a completely
different way and it's going to be
uncomfortable but I think that's good
Dustin cuz cuz you guys have been real
real comfortable for a while until it's
caught up with you so mhm continue that
but man three $350,000 a year can do a
lot for you guys and it's only working
for the bank right now you'll get there
fast man if you follow this plan this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show hey if you're in over your head
with student loans and tired of getting
calls from collection agencies if
private student loan debt is taking away
your financial piece and you don't see
any way out you need why refi they're
not a debt settlement company and
they're not connected to a bank why refi
refinances defaulted private student
loans that other places won't touch and
gives you a custom loan built for you
based on your ability to pay so when you
refinance your private student loan debt
with Y refi you'll have a payment you
can afford with a low fixed interest
rate you couldn't get anywhere else to
help you stick to your budget and work
the debt snowball and you can save
thousands of dollar to learn more about
this custom refinancing option and a
lumpsum payoff option you could qualify
for after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y re
i.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm George C joined by Rachel Cruz this
is your show so give us a call ATA 825
5225 we'll talk about your life your
money we will give you our unfiltered
opinion and Rachel's a lot nicer than I
Am Naturally she's just a sweetheart and
I tend to be last call I tend to be
abive well some people deserve a hug and
some people you know need a swift kick
but generally our callers I give them
hugs Rachel what we're here for and I
think that will be the case with our
friend di who's in Atlanta what's going
on Deanna hi how you doing we're doing
well how can we help today I am a single
mom of one I live with my family and I
make 53,000 temporarily from home but I
have a 12-year-old felony so sometimes I
cannot pass background checks for the
jobs that I want so I'm not sure what to
do at this point like should I still try
to go to school or still try to become
an entrepreneur or like I'm just stuck
what are you doing right now for work I
am a flaud case manager okay and you
said it's
temporary yes it's a contract okay would
you want to do that
full-time yes I love what I do okay are
there is there more opportunity for it
yes there are more opportunities um I
just I failed one opportunity with a big
four company because of my background
though so I don't know tell me again why
you're not passing the background check
I missed that my I have a 12-year-old
felony oh a f okay 12-year-old felony
that's still on your record does that
fall off at a certain point what is the
plan to kind of circumvent that going
forward I'm not sure it's it's a lot of
money to try to get it
removed okay and then you're saying
should you go to school what would
school do for you what would be the goal
with that I don't have a degree so I
feel like I would beat the competition
as far as having a degree and maybe
computer science or accounting um that's
that's all I know is like accounting and
office administrative okay well there's
a lot of paths I don't know that a
degree is what would make you stand out
I mean someone's paying you $53,000 a
year right now without a degree which
tells me you have
skills yes and experience experience
yeah because I mean honestly Danny there
there will be some career paths that
will require a degree for sure um
accounting you know things like that
that yeah they're going to probably want
to see that but there's a whole other
world out there that don't require
college degrees and you can still make a
great living doing it so um if I were
you how old are you I'm 34 34 okay and
how old how old's your you do you have a
son daughter I have a son who's four
who's four okay so great um yeah so I
mean if if I were in your shoes I
wouldn't necessarily be looking to go
back to school I would probably be
looking for the next gig right that
that's uh in the same context of what
you're working in now because you have
great experience and that's going to
take you really far and then if there
are options that you're like yes maybe I
do want to go back to school here in the
future we don't want you taking on debt
for it but I would look to see you know
if there's Community College to get some
of your prxs there um some online
classes I mean you there's ways to do it
if you want to slowly and with cash but
I just don't want you to believe that
you can't make a great living uh without
a college degree because you can and we
talk to a lot of people on this show
that do it um and so I I believe in you
enough I mean you have a very great job
right now like you you're very smart to
be able to do what you're doing and so I
would look to see what those skills are
and what you enjoy and see if there's a
path because in a perfect world you know
you would save 60 Grand or whatever it
is to get a degree and save that money
and right be be working instead of that
so Roi on it do you have any debt right
now de yes I have 40,000 in debt just
because of my car and um you know 3,000
in credit cards but I plan on PING the
credit cards down just to improve my
credit but I do have an expensive car
okay what's the what's the car
worth um I haven't got it appraised yet
okay what's what do you owe on it I owe
37 I I owe roughly 38,000 on it oh yeah
well I would Kelly Blue Book it when you
get off the call with us okay and if you
can get what you put into it you know
without being underwater I'd get rid of
that car and drive something cheap for
now do you have any money
saved yes I have $2,000 saved good good
for you good start so here's the your
game plan for the next few months cuz
you're living with family so you don't
have any bills right no no big bills so
what if we could use that wonderful
$53,000 salary and we start throwing you
know know $1,000 $2,000 a month into
that savings account and once you have a
nice chunk of change in there to buy a
used car we can sell that car hopefully
for what it's worth or even more and
that way you can get out from under this
thing leaving you with you know you'll
be knocking out these credit cards real
soon right so now you're debt free
making 53 Grand yeah what's your car
payment a month
$740 yeah so if you could imagine that
just being back in your pocket right I
mean there yeah because your car payment
is very high compared to your income so
I would say it's pretty much a
requirement I would sell the car so I
would do that as soon as you get some
money saved to buy a cheap used car to
get you where you need to go it's not
going to be a pretty car it's not going
to be the car you're driving now uh but
it will relieve so much of that pressure
and if you'll hold on the line di I want
to give you a copy of my new kids book
I'm glad for what I have because as
you're on this journey of figuring out
your money and possibly selling car your
car and you're going to be working to
pay off this credit card debt and
uh you're in a big transition and I
think it's just a great conversation to
be had with uh with your son and and I
and girl I I just think that there's so
much ahead of you I think you you're
doing a really really good job thank you
thank you well hey Di we're pulling for
you hang on the line we'll send you
Rachel's new kids book and uh man a
single mom alone is a warrior but one
that has that kind of background that
has overcome so much and that is doing
so well I'm just so proud of you and I
have full faith that someone is going to
hire you without a degree because
Dianna's the secret sauce not the piece
of paper that says Dianna did some
school work so we believe in you David
is up next in Gainesville Florida David
what's going
on Hi how are you we're doing well how
can we help
today well I have I'm embarrassed I have
messed my finances up pretty much my
whole life I'm 59 years old and want to
take better care of my wife
who uh has been had to quit her job we
we don't have her income anymore she has
a permanent brain injury from a
concussion I'm sorry she has Crohn's
disease
oh and uh she's just been diagnosed with
some cancer oh David I'm so
sorry sorry no no you're fine I've been
I've been a kid I've been a adolescent
my whole life I I've been well worth
money and now she's suffering for
it uh we don't have a lot of debt I do
make decent money and I just don't know
where it goes yep how much are you
making a
year this year is my worst year it's
only going to be about
62,000 and it's because of many many
doctors appointments she can't go alone
she can't yeah do these things alone we
have nobody to help us so I have to take
off work to do it and thankfully I work
for an excellent company good but and
how much debt do you guys
have we have about $26,000 in medical
okay um small credit card debt of about
um and then a few tiny purchases of some
household
items uh probably total
2,000 okay that's it okay but I don't
know where my money goes well we're
going to help you David we're going to
take a short break but I want to carry
this over because there's a lot to
unpack here and I want to make sure that
we serve you well especially while
you're going through such a difficult
time and before we go to the break I
want to let you know that you can
release the shame and the guilt and the
baggage we've all made mistakes man that
makes you over 12 years old the the big
thing is what are we going to do now
what does 60-year-old David want to be
65-year-old David what does the next
right step look like as we take care of
your ailen wife and we're going to walk
you through that right after the break
so please hang on the line David and
we'll be back with you in just a
[Music]
moment
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based Health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion in healthcare
costs chm is an affordable alternative
to insurance that gives you the freedom
and empowers you to live out your values
and you can join at any time so find out
more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Rachel Cruz
before the break we were talking to
David in Gainesville and we still have
him on the line let me recap his
situation his wife has been through it
healthwise can no longer work is dealing
with a cancer
diagnosis and he makes 62 they've got
26,000 in medical debt 2600 on credit
cards some other uh little debts hanging
around and we just want to wrap our arms
around them and see what we can do to
help him take the right Next Step David
are you still with us yes sir was that a
fair
recap yes sir okay wonderful well
welcome back so let's walk through some
of the numbers and and get you kind of a
game plan moving forward so you're 59
years old how old's your
wife 56 okay and you are now the sole
income for the family and you're trying
to take care of her and so having to
take time off of work to do that which
is also limiting some of your income
correct yes sir okay and you do have
some money and
savings no absolutely none none so we're
paycheck to paycheck right now yes are
you able to cover your bills are you
current on all
bills two credit cards are in
collections okay and what about your are
we able to put food on the table cover
the renter mortgage cover the utility
bills that's one of the embarrassing
things I can put food on the table we
have no rent I drive a truck for a
living and we live in the truck you live
in the
truck yes sir what kind of truck is this
is it a livable
situation it's a semi it's a 8 by8
box how long have you guys been
been doing that
David five years four years excuse me
four years and is that um purely a finan
because you don't have the margin to pay
a rent or a mortgage or is that because
you guys are on the move all the time
and it's like what
you decided just some bad some bad
places that I work we made a move to
Florida um and we have a fifth wheel
Trader that is in a in an area that we
stay stay and on the weekends but
there's there's no rent there it's the
company that I work for lets me keep it
there okay is there do do you think it
would be prudent to find a more stable
living situation for
her if we just found a cheap place to
rent
I we would love to but I've got the
finances so messed up that I I'm not
saying I can't afford it I just don't
know where it goes I don't know why we
don't have
it so you make $62,000 what does your
monthly take-home
pay monthly take-home it it see it
varies a lot of that's because the
doctor's appointments if this was an an
normal year it would be around
um around five grand a month okay so
you're making closer to that's a a good
year though so these days is it closer
to three grand a
month yeah I don't know that's where
we're having trouble too we don't we
don't understand because if one week
we've had two doctor's appointments I
miss out on so many loads that my
paycheck is like $500 when it's normally
take home 1300
1400 um and David for these doctors
appointments CU you're having to miss
workk is it is she able to drive herself
or is it that she actually needs she
needs you to phys she can't physically
Drive she's no longer able to drive she
can't stand very long okay um gets dizzy
she just can't be alone Y and you guys
have no family where where is your
family right now do you guys have any
closest closest family would be my
father in Illinois and he's 90 years old
yeah and we have a
41y old daughter in Illinois
that do you guys have a Rel nice but not
much help okay
okay um
um because in a perfect scenario David
what I would want for you guys is a
place to live um especially going
through all the medical stuff um so you
keep saying yeah we don't know where
it's going we don't know where it's
going so uh we and we hear that all the
time right that's not just you a lot of
people feel that way because there's not
an intentional Act of where this
paycheck is going so I would say two
things on my end and George can walk you
through some more stuff but um we want
to gift you every dollar premium and FPU
which is financial pece University our
nine lesson course but that every dollar
premium David is going to help you guys
budget and you're going to bring your
paycheck in and you're going to say okay
this is what we're planning on making
we're going to have to guesstimate right
because you may not know exactly but we
think that we can at least make this now
we're going to plan out to the Cent
where every single dollar is going and
there's not going to be out to eat
there's not going to be all this I mean
you guys are we say rice and beans beans
and rice like your grocery budget's
nothing you going be eating spaghetti
and tacos and cheap I mean cheap food
you're going to go as cheap as you can
on everything see where that ends up and
what margin that is um and then I think
I think a good goal for you guys in the
next few months once you kind of get
that in order then is to be able to find
find a place to rent um and again I I
don't know where exactly location wise
but you want to make sure um especially
if if it's a good month where you guys
are you know around
$11,200 a month probably so that's going
to be um you know one bedroom apartment
or just something just to give some
level of stability from a living
situation point and the second thing
David which I know is really difficult
but we we have to figure out how to
solve this problem is the income and so
if we're going to be losing income by
taking her to doctor's appointments and
stuff what are things at night that
maybe three nights a week that you're
doing something because the income
um is one of the harder parts of this
formula and and I know the life
situation you guys are in it almost
feels impossible but I think that's
going to give you guys some breathing
room if you can find extra work either
with your current job and taking on more
or finding something a side hustle or
something at night because again upping
that income is going to be it's going to
be really big and David question on the
insurance side and medical bills are you
able to cover those future bills does
she have health
insurance uh we have health insurance
the what the medical bills are are
what's out of pocket okay after
we've because I want to make sure you
have the right type of insurance to
avoid going another 25 Grand into
medical debt have you hit your out-of
pocket
max yes okay so that's good at least for
the rest of the year for this year yes
and then it'll restart and so we need to
start looking at those numbers I want
you to start saving towards that so that
we don't go further into debt as we
continue to take care of her um so
that's one piece of the puzzle is the
ongoing Medical Care is going to
continue to rack
up on top of getting rid of these other
debts so using your income what you're
going to want to do is Lay these all out
the facts are going to help you lay out
every single little debt from smallest
to largest and you're going to start
attacking the little one with a
Vengeance and the one and the credit
cards in collections David I would get a
hold of them and see if you can settle
cuz usually if it's within Collections
and get it in writing if they will but
and tell them your situation like I
don't have it like I don't have the
money I and if you scrape together you
know if you have $2,000 in these credit
card bills it might take 400 bucks yeah
and you scrape together four five $600
and you're like I can pay you now some
they most of the time will settle to the
point that it's in collections and if
they do get it in writing but I would I
would go down that Avenue for sure
because you're not being immoral in that
you genuinely don't have the money I
mean like you don't and sometimes
they'll negotiate with you and you can
actually lower that and the same thing
will go for this medical debt see if you
can settle that negotiate that because
you guys truly don't have the money
you're living in the truck right now
trying to take care of her trying to
work and so I I have faith that we we're
going to get you out of this situation
but it might be a really difficult year
or two to get some Financial footing
under you so that you're able to take
care of her and have some Breathing Room
not just with your time but with your
money well can I tell say two things
real quick sure I know that's going
happen because the Lord has
provided very well and it was like a
slap in the head he
said I've given you what you need now
you need the tools and that's where you
guys come in oh David that's beautiful
thank you for that we're going to also
on top of giving you Financial Peace
University on top of every dollar
premium we want to go one more step and
give you a free financial coaching
session uh with one of our Ramsay
coaches and so they're going to walk you
through this in a way we can't do here
on air in a few minutes uh but I
appreciate the call one last thing we're
going to give you every dollar I'm going
to walk people through how to use every
dollar in a webinar happening tomorrow
everydollar.com budgeting we'll make
sure you get signed up for that and
everyone listening can sign up for that
as well man we are all pulling for you
David everyone listening for you and
your wonderful wife this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
a
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
bestselling author Rachel Cruz who is a
newly minted author of a kids book
called I'm glad for what I have and I'm
excited to read it to my little 2 and
1/2 month-old I've heard you can do that
Rachel many people messaged me you
should you
should always be reading and she'll
learn contentment from 2 months old what
a gift what a gift good what a great dad
you are George I've been told that if I
had a nickel Rachel for every I'd have
one nickel maybe from you oh that's fun
well we're taking your calls at aa825
5225 we'll talk about your life and your
money Jared joins us in Salt Lake City
to kick us off Jared welcome to the
show hi thank you sure what's
happening um well I was just kind of
wondering your guys's opinion
um right now me and my wife
are full-time employees at the family
farm and
uh we're we're going to move away um and
my grandparents who own the farm are
about to go on a like one
your religious thing um so they're not
going to be around at the farm to kind
of run things so the only people left at
the farm would be my aunt and uncle and
I kind of feel like when the time comes
for us to leave there's going to be
some you know kind of we really need you
to stay um and I don't really know what
to do how old are
you uh 23 and my wife's
22 shared I want to release you
from any burden that you are feeling
right now you are carrying something
that you don't need to carry I
understand why you're a great
guy but this is not your responsibility
this this Farm it's not this is
something that you guys have chosen for
a season to be a part of but you're also
23 and if you handcuff yourself to
something like this especially a family
business there's going to be a lot of
resentment and a lot of pain that you
don't have to carry and that you don't
need to live in so are you for your aunt
and uncle are
you is it a story you've made up in your
head Jared or have they have you all had
discussions actually in reality about
this um so I've discussed moving way
with my aunt and uncle and I'm kind of
too afraid to talk about it with my
grandparents um because you really do
need the help um but why does it have to
be you are you the only person on planet
Earth capable of
helping sometimes it feels like you're
not there it is and they've probably
made you feel that way they're like
you're so helpful we can't imagine doing
this without you you guys are so great
and you're married
right yeah did your wife sign up to be a
part of this family farm for the rest of
her
life um I guess not you know kind of
want to move away and farm you know
we're really passionate about
agriculture that's really what we want
to do but um well you're not doing
anything I have a question why do you
want to move away what's the is it just
to kind of have your own thing is it
what's the motivation for that um kind
of to have our own thing um you know my
dad doesn't work there so the kind of
writing's on the wall there like i' work
my whole life but I kind of just be an
employee you know yeah um and right now
we rent the my grandparents old
house which also doubles as the Farm's
office and there is nowhere near us that
is even close to within budget like at
all what are you making reason we can
work there uh I make about 40,000 and
then my wife makes maybe about 5 to
10,000 on top of that okay she working
on the farm
too yeah you guys are severely
underpaid she makes she makes $10,000 a
year she working
full-time no no I guess my wife doesn't
work full-time I guess I said that wrong
but she just kind of does uh okay
clinical stuff you know um which works
out good it works out really well
because we we have a like a year and a
half old and then we've got another one
on the way so it's congratulations nice
to she can work and be a mom at the same
time yeah yeah so what happens let's say
you snapped your fingers where would you
go and what would you
do
um we would be farming uh down south
from us and we' probably be just farming
produce um but that means you need to
have some land how would that
work
so her her family lives down south from
us and we
probably maybe move in with them for a
little while and then uh I want you to
get your own place and have some
Independence I want you relying Less on
family because it's going to add these
weird handcuffed situations like you
found yourself in so what would it take
for you guys to live on your own rent
your own place have your own Financial
stability and then do your own
thing um I've kind of looked at that uh
I need to get my CDL and then maybe uh
have a full-time CDL job I line up right
when I get out of the farm and then kind
of use that money to buy some property
okay do you guys have any
debt um so we got all our student loans
paid off and the only debt we have now
is my truck and I only owe like 1,700
bucks left on it okay so we can knock
that out quick what were your degrees
leave it there to build the credit um we
didn't we didn't finish our degrees out
okay so what I would say Jared if I were
you guys you're 23 you guys are figuring
out life I you're you're starting a
family and you've had a great
opportunity working on the Family Farm
but you know in your gut it's not going
to be the longterm play so Jared you're
going to have to have the uncomfortable
conversation and here's the deal to to
be unclear is to be unkind to be clear
is to be kind and Jared has to be very
clear kind be kind in the clearness but
you need to be very clear with your aunt
and uncle and I would have the
discussion personally sooner than later
and just to say hey we don't have a time
frame because you don't right now Jared
I mean you guys are talking about maybe
we'll maybe we'll move in here I kind of
got to get this license you don't really
have a plan right now there's not a
concrete like hey this is exactly what
we're going to do step one step two step
three we can do it in 18 months and boom
you don't have that yet but you know
it's coming so I would have the
conversation just out of respect for
them so that they can plan and to say
hey guys uh here's kind of what our gut
saying we're probably not going to be
here full-time uh my wife and I we're
going to sit down we're going to create
a plan create a timeline and once we do
that we're going to let you guys know
that so that you have the time to
backfill our positions if you need to
but I just want to give you the heads up
that we're not going to be here long
term and you need to have that
conversation Jared and and it's that and
regardless of how they react that's on
them
nothing in this means that you were born
into this thing and you have to do this
thing right I mean like that's I work
for a family business I'm like I would
be miserable if I felt like this is
where I had to be all the time and I was
forced in it and I didn't want to have
some awkward conversation life is too
short Jared life in your wife your wife
deserves a husband and you guys deserve
a marriage that's yours fully so don't
live with someone else's expectations so
create a plan communicate it early and
be guilt-free of it because that's
okay
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us net week worked for ramsy and it
will make a difference for your business
business too join the more than 34,000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
[Music]
Ramsey
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by the Rachel Cruz
this hour and the number to call Isle
5225 this is a rare combo When Rachel
and I get to host together we we do host
smart money happy hour another show on
Ramy Network where we have a great time
usually with a cocktail in hand very
different style little bit more relaxed
on that that's right we're re up tight
over here we we're gonna we're going to
do the ramsy show we got this intense
voices on for this show yeah we we put
on our big boy pants today but hey if
you want to check out all of the shows
we got so many on the Ramsey network
with our friends Ken John Rachel uh I've
got a YouTube channel so there's always
something coming out from us there's a
you can't be bored you can't say we
don't put out enough content we're
trying to help as many people as we can
out there so we appreciate all of you
who tun in and if you guys love it will
you share the show and subscribe to some
of these put reviews out there it's just
really helpful um when you'all spread
the word sharing it with friends and all
of it um again we want people to get
control of their money and I think it's
one of the best ways to do it it's free
you can listen any time cost you nothing
yeah so share it with your friends with
your family uh and again subscribe if
you can leave reviews all that's so
helpful all right let's get to the
phones Danielle is in Los Angeles what's
going on
Danielle hi hi you guys I hope this was
a fun one for you thank you we needed a
soft toss here
Dani so my husband and I were 48 and 52
um we have a lump of cash about
$112,000 right now that we'd saved up
for taxes cancer messed with us earlier
in this year and so we just weren't
doing anything with the money but now
we're past all of that stuff and we are
past cancer oh I'm so thankful that's
awesome congratulations um thank you um
so we are behind on retirement savings
for our age we only have about
$200,000 combined between the two of us
and we have a mortgage balance of
$337,000 that we are very anxious to pay
off we've like had a lot of things come
up since we've been debt free in 2017 so
we haven't been able to like push on the
mortgage like I want to and I want to
know if you guys would
condone playing around with the money a
little bit like getting a brand new car
which we've never bought a brand new car
doing some home upgrades or if we need
to be smarter and like just lump it into
investment because we were so behind or
push on the mortgage what's your
household
income um we were at about 300K a year
that is good news okay and outside of
the retirement what kind of equity do
you have in the home
a lot our our home is probably worth
about
1.6 million if we were to sell it but
we're not I mean we're not moving we
have young kids still well you've got
about 1.2 plus million in equity in the
home yeah okay that's good news but I
want to have all of the equity sure yeah
well you're going to knock this mortgage
out real quick making 300,000 I'd love
to see you guys get aggressive now that
you have this but the question is we
have this pile of money is this above
and beyond your emergency fund yes we
have an emergency fund besides this Plus
112 okay so if I'm in Danielle's shoes
I've got this mortgage we're behind on
retirement and you want to buy a brand
new car and you know we tell people just
so the listeners are clear the only time
you should buy a brand new car if you
want to is once you have a million
dollar net worth and the cars should add
up to no more than half of your annual
income so you guys are not violating any
principes so far but the question is the
opportunity cost that's what you're
struggling with yeah and we're thinking
that we would probably spend about 60 K
which sounds ridiculous to us on a car
but because we've never we've always
bought used cars okay um but yeah I'm
guessing I'm wondering if like it's just
not worth it to do that yet we should
catch up or at least shovel this to do
you need a new car Danielle what's your
current okay it's more just for fun yeah
yeah no I it's because I drive a boring
gray van and I want something more fun
for me yeah that would still fit my
family so y okay we may have different
answers on this Rachel I I feel like
there's some Middle Ground here where we
can get you a great car and we can
shovel a bunch of money into retirement
much how much for the gray van could you
get how much what do you mean you how
much could I get if I sold it I mean
probably like oh it would be like oh no
no no it'd be more probably like 25 we
just few years ago but you're not
driving a hoop low mileage no no no it's
a nice fand like about it is nice except
for that I know that to me I have
trouble thek lot because I forget what
it looks
like I love it just slap a live like no
one else bumper sticke Danielle I would
yeah you can get 25 for it which is
awesome um yeah you know I would
probably throw another you know I'm just
throwing numbers out
1520 go get a great you I would get a
used car I don't think you need a brand
new one I mean George and I were just
talking about cars one of specific car
what's the on a specific model that's
coming out next year it's an electric
van you know the VW Buzz vans that are
coming out that are so cute and they're
electric and it would fit my family and
it would fit our lifestyle and how much
is it going for 60 well there's no it I
think all in all it would be about 60
for what we we need to like install an
electric plug and do some things so that
would be my plan okay it's really
specific yeah well you got time is the
car even available no it's coming out
next year I'm planning ahead I'm a
planner that's good I feel like I'm I'm
the type where if I eat my vegetables
and I finish my plate then I can have
some dessert and so I feel like for you
you're in a similar boat where if we
attack some of the mortgage we put some
of this and maxed out our retirement
accounts for the year I would feel good
about money left over going toward
upgrading the car and if it's a year
from now maybe we start a sinking fund
separately for the car to save it's safe
to get what you what you want it's not
like you guys I mean we get people
calling the show and their car is
breaking down they have to get a new one
or they have to sell it because they
have too much car debt and they have to
find another one you guys aren't in
those di traits you just hate the van
which I totally you know understand that
so uh so yeah I would do what George
said I would kind of use this money
split it three ways put some at the
mortgage I would put some in retirement
and then map out and say okay how much
is left after that and then how much do
we need to save per month and again
you're not in a rush to get this this
new car but what if it took but what if
it took 12 months and you put some money
away every single month save towards it
and then when it comes out or six months
after it comes out and you're like okay
we have the cash for it and you kind of
just slowly walked I think you would
feel more peace at that than just kind
of jolting and and making kind of a snap
decision I like the idea of planning and
putting some money
aside the the low amount that we have in
retirement doesn't scare you I mean it
scares me how old are you guys how old
are you guys 48 and 52 okay so we got we
only have 200k so let's say you had 12
more working years making
$300,000 I think you can have a fine
retirement if you max out all retirement
do catchup contributions you may use a
ta a taxable brokerage account outside
of that if you start to run out of
options so you guys will be okay but
that's like we're getting on a plan here
we're not just going to spend
willy-nilly for the next 10 years and
we're going to knock out this
mortgage yeah so I would have a set game
plan and I like to if if I was in your
shoes Danielle truthfully I probably pay
off the mortgage and then feel really
good about getting a whatever the heck
kind of car I wanted and you guys could
do that in a few years it wouldn't be a
long
time yeah so we're talking three years
and we attack this morgage you guys came
out of a hard year Danielle with a
cancer scare and and everything that you
guys have walked through so there's a
level of an emotion for you that is
understandable but it's also you feel
this like oh my gosh I Just Want to Have
Fun can I just please just have fun and
you're looking for an outlet to do that
and I'm wondering if you can kind of
scratch that itch elsewhere while still
being wise with this money that you guys
have because I think this money could go
further than just throwing it at a new
car um I think you're right but I do
Wonder but I'm like you know for this
man I'm like I don't know is there again
you're not violating any principles here
so we're not going to yell at you if you
do it you'll be okay but I think because
of your own fear that you haven't done a
good enough job with retirement enjoy
the car at this point have some guilt
yeah cuz it feels like more an emotional
purchase than like a rational one you
know yeah I think you're all that's very
much right that's exactly what I wanted
to do I wanted to feel really great
after getting through it Y and and
that's totally understandable but see if
you can celebrate go and spend $400 at
an amazing dinner in La that's true and
go you know go big like go do something
that you're just like oh I want to like
kind of scratch that spending itch cuz I
get that I feel that I love to spend
Rachel's not scared to spend I have a
little more of the guilt so this was a
very balanced call here but Danielle
thanks for letting us talk it through
with you we're honored to take the call
so glad to hear that this cancer is
behind you and we hope it stays that way
this is the Ramsay
[Music]
show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 45% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz we've
got a lot a lot of fun things happening
at Ramsey solutions.com and if you head
to the store there's a lot more fun
happening because we've got the
Christmas Cash giveaway right now we're
giving away 500 bucks a week $5,000
grand prize you can enter every day for
more chances to win we also have the $12
sale which which is a killer deal to get
some of our bestselling books like The
Total Money Makeover baby steps
millionaires own your past change your
future some of the questions for humans
decks and while you're at the store
you'll see some new and exciting
products and I'm biased Rachel but uh my
new book Breaking Free from broke is
there on prale as well as your brand new
kids book I'm glad for what I have just
released yesterday uh there's also the
2024 Ramsey gold planner we've got the
Rachel Cruise wallet in Navy I mean we
have it in camel but you know why not
have camel that you're George it's not
with a K I was a little upset about that
missed opportunity know my the color
palette but we're going Navy this this
season very excited about it love a good
Navy very classy so you can check that
all out it's a One-Stop shop for all of
your Christmas uh shopping just go to
ramsy solutions.com store to check it
all out let's get to the phones sha JY
in Irvine California Shawn how can we
help you today hi guys how you doing
doing well doing great good good good so
I just had a quick question um so I
currently you know I'm not in I'm not in
debt really that much really just from
school and um a surgery that I had but
that not it doesn't even amount to like
20 grand which is totally manageable um
but on the other hand I don't I have
about seven credit cards um with very
little balance if anything they're just
my remedial um uh they're pay for like
Netflix you know like stuff like that on
payment plans every month for those for
that kind of stuff um however it does
amount to over
$100,000 of open Credit Now with that
much are you trying to impress us Sean
because it's not working so far no no no
it's scary because I I need to get I
need to I'm gonna buy a house soon why
and what was that
why um because we're our rent is just
going out of control that I'm paying
right now and it's almost amounting to a
new house payment um a mortgage if I
just paid like $1,000 doll more I'd be
in a mortgage how much do you
make so I make about $90,000 a year okay
and you
married no no okay who's you kept saying
hour hour rent hour
rent oh sorry you kept saying hour rent
is going up who's the hour is there
someone else in the picture
oh a roommate roommates got it how old
are you so I'm 31 Oh I thought you were
younger the way you were talking
okay you're just too you're just too so
insult no I meant it I meant it in a
good way I meant it in a good way Sean
um you have a very young energetic
voice so you're 31 you want to buy a
house for
Shawn yeah okay which will somehow save
you
money well yeah cuz I have like
$170,000 saved up for this why are you
hanging on to debt when you have 170,000
sitting there no I don't um so the ho or
sorry the um the hospital bill is
interest free so um if I'm not paying
interest on it I figured not to so what
do you owe in medical bills well I want
to know from Sean what do you what do
you calling us for what's your what's
your number one question should you buy
a house is that the number one thing
that you want to know with lenders like
seeing how much credit cards I've have I
have is there a problem with um that
they see me having so many credit cards
do I need to close some I don't want to
close any because it hurts you know I
know it hurts your credit score um okay
but I'm so Sean you called a kind of a
different show just so our advice is
going to be probably opposite of what
you usually hear because we are not fans
of credit cards we're not even fans of a
credit score we're not fans of keeping
around debt we want debt in that entire
game that everyone plays out of your
life 100% forever ever amen and that
Sean's $9,000 that he makes is all his
there's no game to play he has cash in
the bank that's saved in a high yield
savings account for an emergency fund he
has a good down payment he's funding
retirement and he's doing things that
are good for sea this whole game that
you're playing is normal it's what most
people do but here at Ramsay it is a
completely different mindset to the
point that we would say close all of
your credit cards pay everything off get
a debit card pay for Netflix with a
debit card and your credit score will
lower because it is all mathematically
calculated by debt there's about seven
seven layers of your credit score and it
all has to do with debt so when you stop
going into debt when you start paying
off debt and eliminating debt that score
inevitably will go down to the point in
about 12 months after paying off all
your debt it will be undetermined it
goes to a place that you can they can't
determine your credit score because you
haven't had debt in over a year so then
you will do a process called manual
underwriting where they will actually
underwrite you a mortgage but that's
after you're debt free with a fully
funded emergency fund and at least 5%
down for that mortgage because for so
many people the thought is well if I
just had a house because yes like you
said in some people their rent is even
more expensive than what a mortgage
would be right I mean it is insane what
people are paying for rent so I totally
hear you but when you own a home it's
very expensive when things go out
there's not a landlord to be there
there's not roommates there to split up
the rent right I mean it becomes a very
expensive process and it's a great thing
home ownership should be part of your
financial picture that's a part of
Building Wealth but we want you to do it
in the right
way so okay so we're so opposite of
everything so against credit cards yeah
right yep so if let's just say I mean I
I have a business of my own and I wanted
to expand and use credit for myself how
do you without credit cards how do you
get expansion and Trust from lenders
with why do you want more credit and
more lenders you just told me you were
frightened by a $100,000 line of credit
well no no no but like let's just say
Okay so let's say I I need to get
something for my my business right some
huge purchase that's gonna help me make
money in the in the long run okay you
save up and pay cash so you move at the
speed of cash if I pay that cash though
yes am I essentially draining my my my
savings and all my
um no what's draining your savings is
making payments to 14 different
lenders you're going to spend the money
anyways we're just telling you do it
upfront when you have the money so you
don't make stupid decisions that there
no risk and that's the other thing is
you add on so much risk especially in a
business we actually have a business
conference going on right now with small
business owners from all over the
country and it's amazing especially in
small business that people out leverage
themselves and when something doesn't
work the amount of stress that is caused
on that it it never ends up good and so
teach them to run their bus completely
debt free and so even for this company
Sean we have a th team members and we
only have business debit cards we don't
have a single dime of debt on this place
it's a $300 million paid for building
and we moved at the speed of cash Dave's
been doing this for 30 years this
building just opened four years ago and
so it's a slower pace you're wanting to
move very quickly and there is a lot of
podcasts and shows that will help you do
that by leveraging debt we just happen
to swim upstream and go countercultural
yeah and and too Sean part of this you
have to understand is that is that debt
there's a weight that you carry with
debt and everyone does and now in our
culture today it's so normal that people
get used to what they carry around but
there is a freedom that is caused when
you don't owe anyone anything and that
autonomy is what's missing in our
culture today and that autonomy of being
able to make your own choices being able
to have options because no one you don't
no bank is in your life there's there's
nobody that you are financially attached
to you have complete autonomy and
there's power in that to be able to use
your income to build wealth on the
mathematical financial side but there's
an emotional spiritual side of money too
that a lot of people don't talk about
and there's a freedom that comes when
there is no payments you're not owed by
anyone you make different decisions in
life when you don't have that
risk I never really thought about like
that yeah okay I want you to hold in the
line uh Sean because Emily's going to
pick up uh I would love to give you
Total Money Makeover it's the
bestselling book that we have here at
Ramsey written by Dave and it'll walk
you through the seven baby steps uh it's
a quick read very easy and this kind of
it'll give you an overall picture of it
and I hope I hope you're enlightened by
it Sean I love that you called because
uh call us back I want to hear your your
millions of people build wealth and get
control of their money it's just a
totally different way than the world
does it so yeah I'm glad you found this
though I've personally done manual
underwriting Sean without a credit score
after I cut up my cards and between r
and I we have zero credit cards that's
what it amounts to and our wallets are
lighter and our souls are lighter for it
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz this
is your show America you can give us a
call atle
225 we're doing something fun this
Friday November the 10th 12:30 EAS
Eastern Time 11:30 central time I'll be
doing a free every dooll training
showing you how to break the paycheck to
paycheck cycle in just 90 days now this
isn't just for people who are broke you
might be doing the baby steps you're out
a debt you still don't have the margin
to invest that 15% to throw at the house
to save up for that vacation I'm going
to show you step by step how to create
margin in your budget by spending less
by making more and by using our every
dollar budgeting tool so join me it's
totally free to sign up but you got to
sign up to get the link every
dollar.com budgeting is the place to go
everydollar.com budgeting and if you
can't make that exact time don't worry
about it we'll send you a link you can
watch the replay but I hope to see many
of you there virtually will be answering
your questions and it will be a good
time all right Esther is in Logan Utah
Esther how can we help
today hey thanks for having me on um so
I kind of have a loaded question I'll
just give you a little background info
real quick so my husband and I finished
baby step three and we want to buy a
home so we don't throw away our money on
rent essentially but we plan to move
within the next four years after my
husband graduates college and
commissions as an officer in the Air
Force um it's also important to note
that we do not qualify to buy a home for
the next 18 months because we are
self-employed so basically we'd only be
in the home for two years so our
question is do we save money for a down
payment or spend our
elsewhere that was a loaded question
Esther a lot to unpack there um so how
old are you two so I'm 22 and my husband
is 23 okay and you're in baby step three
yep when when will you be done with that
oh you're done sorry we just finished
okay so now we're on to what we call
baby step 3B you want to save up a
homeown payment and you're going to do
that how quickly do you have a
goal um our goal is within a year how
much can you save in a
year we could probably save a little
over 20k so if we're looking to buy like
a $400,000 home it'd be about 3% or
sorry 5 per. and what's your household
income um right now we're both working
part-time and we make about 80k per year
but that is projected to increase okay
so s i when it comes to buying a home
timeline wise I wouldn't buy one that
I'm not there at least 5 years so if you
guys won't even qualify for something
and you're only going to be there to I
would I would probably rent um until
he's out of the Air Force and you guys
know would you guys be stationed and
move around do you think for for a good
season yeah yeah we would be yeah so do
you guys um recommend like do you guys
not recommend buying a home and then
renting it out no because you're going
to move and now you're going to be a
long a a longdistance landlord and then
you're going to want to buy something
else and then you're not going to have
the money to do it cuz it's all tied up
in this mortgage that you still have and
so you can see how it creates this weird
cycle of risk and
stress yeah so I'm GNA pause on this
dream I want you to be homeowners but
Rachel's right I want you to think
longterm and not just what's going to
help us in the next two years and you
said these words at the beginning that I
want to call out cuz I've heard this
from many many people you said we're
throwing away money on
rent can I free all the renters out
there you're not throwing away money on
rent
renting is not a sin renting is buying
patience and it's very wise and I know
it hurts but you know what else how
expensive home ownership can really be
and you buy at the top of the market and
then you know who knows and then you
guys go to sell it in two years and you
don't know where it's going to be so
there's just not enough time for it to
fluctuate up and down to have some kind
of
sustainability um to write out any weird
ups and downs so yeah I would um I would
still be having the dream though Esther
and if you guys how long will you guys
be moving because I know as military
families uh you know you move every what
18 months two years do you know what
what what the future will look like how
long he'll be doing that for yeah I mean
I'm assuming it'll be at least 10 years
okay so it'll it'll be a while but with
that money would it be would it be silly
to upgrade our
cars what what money do you have do you
what what do you have in savings or
you're just talking about future savings
yeah future savings yeah I think
upgrading your cars I think is great and
again
in 10 years you guys will be in your
mid-30s and if that's the first time
that you're putting a great down payment
for a house I I think I mean if anything
it just kind of buys you time to say hey
we have a decade to save a great down
payment maybe even 50% of it 70% of it
right I mean you have you have a while
because especially with military
families going from City to City short
term I wouldn't recommend yeah buying a
house um so yeah you you guys have time
on your side and it's just going to be
hard eser I think you're probably going
to look around and and see your friends
on I don't know Instagram keys and
smiling new house yeah and it's and this
that's just not going to be your story
it's just not smart financially for you
guys and that's okay and and you have
plenty of time to be homeowners you have
plenty of time to do all of this um and
you're going to do it the right way in a
really Wise Way and and I think that
patience is going to be key but it's
going to be a level of contentment
Esther that you're going to you're going
to have to find but thank you guys for
your service I know there's so much
sacrifice in that for you all so um tell
your husband thank you thanks for the
call Esther tion joins us up next in
Washington DC tion what's going on hey
how you guys doing I'm excited to be on
um so I have a question um I recently
acquired um or inherited some rental
property or property I also have my own
rental property U but I do also have
some debt um so I'm trying to figure out
you know what's going to be the best
approach for me for paying down the debt
and then and also investing uh for my
future cool how old are
you uh so I just turned
38 all right and what's your household
income um so I make about
160 great and how much debt do you
have okay so the debt so I have um
53,000 spread out between three credit
cards
ooo what what what's what's what's on
the credit cards just lifestyle or a
little bit of Lifestyle um I also a
little bit of Lifestyle that's
$53,000 worth of Lifestyle well no what
else is there other stuff or is it just
lifestyle um um so I also recently lost
a parent so um I had to put a lot of you
know funeral expenses okay um on credit
cards as well I'm sorry about that a big
portion of it is that where the
Inherited property comes into play it is
okay it is okay oh okay so $53,000 in
credit card debt what else what do you
on your car yeah um so I don't have any
car payment um so I paid for a car in
cash um so no no car payment awesome I
do have a p yeah I have a personal loan
for
$1800 okay any student loans and my I do
I have about 83,000 in student loans
okay and then this property that you
inherited um what's it worth and what's
owed on
it um so it's worth probably around like
300,000 okay and about 70,000 left on it
okay and then you have another oh go
ahead sorry oh yes uh so I do have
another rental property um I paid 110
for it and I currently owe about 80,000
on the property and what's it
worth you think it's worth 110 it's
worth about oh it's worth about 200 I
would say 200,000 okay and then what's
your primary
residence um so right now I'm living
with uh my girlfriend we rent um so no
mortgage on that okay yeah no mortgage
yep okay awesome
um all right I have a plan I don't know
if you're gonna like it oh man I'm ready
to hear I man if I'm in your shoes like
you could slog and try to knock out all
this debt aggressively but I think
selling your rental property would clear
a huge chunk of this and then you could
clear the rest with your future income
and hang on to that family Inherited
property okay it would clear it all
because if you got if it if you could
sell it for 300 no 70 well the the
family one's 300 right yeah yours is yes
200 and you you uh owe
80 yes you have 120 in that one y so if
you wanted to keep the more expensive
one you could do that but one of these
has to go either way you could knock
almost Deb but hey ton when you clear
out your debt like that you can't go
back into credit card debt for lifestyle
so this is going to be a sweep that's
going to help you but tion needs to
change tion or it's not going to work
you're going to be back in the same
position if you're not careful yeah
you're too successful and too smart I'm
excited for you though tion you got some
good stuff ahead future is right my man
this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
m
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my good friend
and fellow Ramsey personality Rachel
Cruz and we are here for you America to
help you take the right next step with
your life and your money the number is
8825 5225 you call us up and we will
give you our opinion and that's a
guarantee Blaine joins us first in
Indianapolis Blain how's it going good
how are you doing well how can we help
today yeah thank you for taking my call
um I am curious about debit cards that
are store specific and if you feel like
they're okay or if You' group these into
cards that you would give the plastic
surgery what a fun question for Rachel
Cruz and I this is right up our alley
I'm gonna be honest I was hoping and
praying that it would be you too cuz I'm
like well maybe there's a little Grace
here your prayers were answered we're
the nice on
I know I have the Target red card I
opened it almost 10 years ago but I have
the version that is specifically a debit
card there is no credit capabilities
comes exactly out of my checking oh I am
so relieved welcome to the I have that
too yes it's great it's a debit card I'm
just curious that the holidays coming up
yeah so what what's your you're saying
is it okay to use like do you have
Rachel and I
blessing not necessarily is it okay but
we've been going through our wallets and
we've just and trying to do like a
cleanup and looking at everything and I
got my new Target card in the mail and I
have to update it and I just sat there
staring at
it what's causing this are you do you
feel like you have a spending problem
are you guys in debt what's your
financial situation like no we are on
baby steps four five and six so we're
both employed full-time we have a three
and a halfy old um a 12-week old so
we're in the stage of buying a lot of
diapers buying a lot of wipes I I feel
that I'm out of that pH
yeah we've done a lot of diaper shopping
at Target yeah so I mean and that's what
and honestly that's where I bought my
diapers and wipes blend with my Target
red card debit card uh because you would
get the gift certificate you would get
like the I don't know it would be like
the% off each purchase and then you get
like gift cards if you spend hundred you
get $20 gift cards all of that which was
great because then I would just roll
that back into diapers and wipes because
that's what I used it for so no I think
it's great I think I think any level of
spending that has convenience with it
and what I mean by that is like the
Amazon app I mean the Target red card I
guess I'd say more the Target app would
fall in this category Apple pay like
when we go and like order I have the
Papa John's apps when we order pizza
Rachel and her Papa John's goodness
gracious I Apple pay with it and it's
great so all of these are conveniences
which is fine but you do end up can tend
to overspend more because there's just
not that level of emotion that you're
feeling cuz you almost feel it more when
you're at T Target swiping your target
debit card or your regular debit card
you at least have some action in it that
you're feeling and knowing money's
leaving your account but when it's just
like Taps on your phone and stuff that's
where I think the subconscious
overspending can really happen because
there's just no friction and having to
have the patience so so no Blain I think
you're totally fine if it's if it's a
debit card you're not borrowing the
money it's coming out of your checking
account you're good to go and if you
feel like you need to pull back on
spending I think that's more of the
question not necessarily the method of
what you're doing yes exactly if you
find yourself going to Target way more
and buying things you normally probably
wouldn't buy just normal woman you can
get 5% we all do that at Target been
there so yes it sounds like you're a
very reasonable logical person I
appreciate the question though because I
think all of our and I think too you
know blae I'm like I have to ask myself
why am I spending the things I'm
spending am I spending it to fill some
kind of void to have some level of
excitement in life to want to feel cute
in that outfit like whatever the thing
is like what's the reason I'm spending
and asking that question is a really
honest one and that's when I I ask
myself as a spender I have to ask myself
that a lot am I doing it just kind of
get the dopamine hit of like oh yeah a
fun Amazon purchase Blaine I don't know
if you've been through Financial Peace
University have
you um we have the full every dollar
class we've watched the first two but we
haven't actually participated in the
class okay so you already have it though
I was going to gift it to you all right
yeah so in in I believe lesson five I
appreciate it yeah absolutely lesson
five it's all about why spending and I
cover five questions in there as part of
my smart spender plan and those
questions will help you regardless of
where you're shopping and the method of
purchase but it really walks through
some simple things am I buying this for
the right reason is one of the big
questions that's the M for motive
affordability is this actually in my
budget have I planned for this research
is this the best option retailer in
price you might find you can get a
better deal elsewhere even outside of
the 5% Target Red Card discount and then
t for timing is now the time to buy it
are there other priorities think about
opportunity cost so those kinds of
questions I feel like will they will
supersede and transcend all of your
spending decisions and help you just go
in and build a habit asking simple
questions before you
purchase awesome well thank you I
appreciate it absolutely thank you
Blaine what a fun Rachel we needed that
question we needed a win this hour and
that was it that's the first call of the
hour George I know that's all I need
Jacob is in New Orleans Jacob what's
going
on hey guys how's it going appreciate
youall having me sure how can we
help did you break up on us I should
sell my house that's my question and
I'll give you the details should you
sell your
house yeah my wife and I just celebrated
our uh threeyear anniversary yesterday a
congratulations yeah thank you thank you
uh we have a son who is also three um he
is uh autistic uh recently we've
discovered and you know they say the
earlier the better so we're trying to do
everything we can to you know give him
the resources the therapy everything
that we can with him and insurance has
been less than helpful um on some of
those things so it's been a challenge um
and as far as goes we have probably
280,000 of death that's all Consumer
Debt uh no 107 or sorry 270 of it is our
house oh okay so you have 10,000 in
Consumer Debt correct okay correct and
uh and probably uh you could probably
tack another two on there just medical
bills sure you know that we're that
we're paying on um and man this house
it's great it's fantastic we wanted to
buy a house to get him you know more I
guess concrete and you know consistency
we were renting I was paying $1,500 a
month to rent and I thought well with
that price we might as well just buy
something and gain a little bit of
equity um so we we did so and the house
that we bought you know we were looking
and looking and looking and we found
this one and it's a great house it's
fantastic but it was at the very top end
of our budget and by the end of closing
and everything I mean it's been wild and
down here in Louisiana with homeowners
insurance and required hurricane and
flood um yeah so my my house note right
now after the first year
uh we went into uh an equity deficit I
don't know what the exact term is but
they basically they ued the note uh to
pay for the increase of wow insurance
we're up against the clock Jacob what's
your what's your mortgage payment and
what's your take-home pay uh so I make
117 a year before
taxes um and our mortgage payment is
2650 that
feels a little high it may not be worth
selling at this point but what I would
do is give it 6 months see if you can
decrease expenses increase income before
I go ahead and sell the house but man if
it's stressing you guys out that much
it's no longer a blessing it's a burden
and for those reasons i' would probably
be out on this thing sorry to hear what
you're going through man this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the ramsy show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel C Cru this
is your show America you can call us at
5225 want to remind you guys in honor uh
Veterans Day we're giving away Financial
Peace University to 10,000 veterans
totally free now through Monday November
13th if you don't know FPU is the proven
fastest way to beat debt and build
wealth it's a nine lesson course and
it's helped nearly 10 million people so
if you're a veteran you want to take FPU
for free it is on us just go to ramsy
solutions.com
veterans and fill out a simple form and
you guys can help us get the word out
there I know we all have a veteran we
love in our life tell them to go to that
link ramsy solutions.com
veterans our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for Home Services neighborly has local
service providers who can repair
maintain and improve your home their
network of experts offers top quality
work and customer service by trained
reliable service providers you can find
the help you need at neighborly decom
Ramsey today's question comes from Chris
in Michigan I know this may be a silly
question to ask however I if I hear your
advice on this I might feel much better
a couple of weeks ago I went to the
grocery store to get a few snacks and
items for the week and the total cost
was $100 With Coupons then on my social
media I started seeing reals and Tik Tok
videos about how bad inflation is today
compared to the 1980s and
90s uh they say that
$300,000 is the new $100,000 in buying
power for homes or to be considered well
off
is this what is what I am seeing just
more than inflation fear porn or is
everything getting worse out there and
I'm just now noticing what are your
thoughts thank you and God bless ooh
okay so Rachel I've seen these videos
there's this real estate guy out there
who makes all these videos comparing the
1950s and 60s and 70s and the prices
then versus What It Takes now and the
income's now and how much more
impossible it feels Y and all it is is
really ring people up to get clicks and
Views and the data is skewed I mean even
on that video it said it has one of
those like context needed click here
like one of those warnings from
Instagram that's like this isn't totally
factual this was taken out of context
from this data from 1950s that only took
into account this and that so right I'm
not I'm not sitting here to parse out
this guy's data and debunk it but is
inflation really that bad for some
people and if you follow the Ramsey plan
and you've been on a budget and you've
stayed out of debt inflation feels more
like a pinch than a punch and depending
on where you are and your housing market
and your lifestyle and if you're in
Canada goodness gracious our our friends
in Canada are going through it Rachel
with their food prices alone right but
is it worse than it ever has been maybe
is it going to crush your life
financially and there's no way to
survive it we need to shake our fists at
the inflation Gods until they do
something about it no so I think it
largely is kind of that inflation fear
porn as he said and there's a lot we can
do about it which is comforting but I
also don't want to minimize the fact
that it's hard I mean there's yeah and I
think there's a reality to like the real
estate side of it right and like it's
yeah houses are insane interest rates
are insane but it's also perspective
because when you look back at certain
times even in the 80s what interest
rates were on houses it was like 16 18%
right for for mortgages and if it
dropped to 12% everyone went crazy and
so we're at you know that sevenish per
and from our perspective especially if
you're a millennial and when you're if
you went and bought a house you know
your first house 10 12 years ago and you
lived in the 2% world for so long that
became normal and then all of a sudden
when it jumps up it does feel like oh my
gosh this is insane but it's been more
insane in the past right so I think it's
all it's all
perspective and yeah I mean I think I
mean you look at tuition for college is
insane uh I mean there's just things
that yeah I think the math can prove it
out but it doesn't mean that it's
impossible it may mean that there's
going to be more patience and you have
to be more on a plan be more intentional
because one more reason to get out of
debt too yeah if you need margin one of
the things stealing from your margin is
your debt and so getting out of debt is
a huge help if you're feeling the pinch
of and I would say this too and I'm not
a historical Economist George I know you
may think that I but I'm not but I would
say life is like it is a roller coaster
it is up and down and there's going to
be good times there's going to be bad
times you know you look at 08 and what
the housing market was it's the opposite
and you know what it is now in the sense
of like how expensive houses are so
things fluctuate in life there's an
election year coming up next year that
always kind of changes the economy to a
degree people hold on to their money
they wait and see I mean things just
they shift all the time so to be in this
permanent mindset that this is how it's
going to be forever and ever amen it's
just not true so well Rachel you always
say you know comparing your life to
someone else's is always going to and
just kind of drinking your own poison in
a sense and so the same goes for
comparing your life to the folks of the
1980s and the 70s and the 60s first of
all do you understand the standard of
life we now have y'all need to get a new
iPhone every single year they didn't
even have a smartphone look at the cars
they I was going to say they were
usually a onecar family the square
footage average square footage of what a
home was in the countertops there was no
white cabinets they were all these small
dilapidated homes and Dinky cars and no
one cared but now we social media no
seat belts remember those days George
walk around the van that's Weir simpler
times Rachel's walking around the van
while it's going 90 miles down the
interstate it's just it was a different
world y'all in so many ways and so yeah
to your point George if you just sit
there and complain about it sure it
hurts and you're like man that' been
nice to have bought a house 5 years ago
sure but you didn't so you are where you
are now so what are we going to do about
it you know there's a level of like this
reality and if you just sit in this can
tell you what doesn't help the Boomers
Doom scrolling Instagram is not going to
get you any closer to your financial
goals so uh you can hit heart on his
thing and live a comment say oh my gosh
he's so right life is so hard or you can
just get up and go to work and take the
side job and get out of debt and do the
hard stuff to get to where you want to
go but I I see both sides of this corn
this those platforms George as you
know Phil um continue to fill your feed
with what you watch that's right so I
opened mine up and it was all T Swift
coming out of a New York restaurant with
all her friends because obviously that's
what I've been looking at recently so
there she all was so if you're Doom
scrolling to your point and you have
like these like you need to be swift
scrolling you yeah just change to
something happier so at least you're not
being continually fed this fear so
remember that too Taylor Swift Paparazzi
videos that's the positivity we need in
today's world sometimes you just you
know escape from Linda's up next in
Olympia Washington how can we help
Linda hi um thank you for taking my call
sure um my husband my husband and I went
through the Financial Peace University
several years ago and we are debt free
awesome amazing
congrats thank you and we are we just um
we have a million dollars now we are wow
well done
Linda yeah so but my question is um we
are both going to retire in about three
years um and we have some cash and we're
trying to figure out where the best
place would be to put the
cash um we have about
$38,000 is just sitting in our bank and
100,000 of that is earning about
4.07% interest but the other 208,000
we're thinking about putting towards
maybe a rental property because we don't
have any of
those um but just wanted to get
your advice on what might be the best
play place to put that sure so you've
got million in your nest tag what are
those uh in what
accounts so my husband has a work
401 Roth account that's
got um let's see
3 360,000 in that and then um our home
is 364,000
uh we have 380 in cash and then I have a
really small retirement count of like
3,200 from when I worked for a company
before okay good for you and you're
going hey should I put it in real estate
should I be investing this what's your
take Rachel yeah I mean I think you guys
at this point I would I would continue
to fund that 15% into your into your uh
retirement as you guys are working for
these years you got paid for house right
our house is paid for so yeah I think I
think diversifying yeah and taking 200
and I'd pay cash for it but also know
Linda when you get into real estate it
sounds all great and wonderful and it is
to a degree but there's a lot of work
involved you're going to have to have
renters you're going have to do
background checks you're going to have
to fix stuff when things break there's a
it's a kind of a part-time job so just
know you take on a level of
responsibility when you do that route
it's a great route cuz I like the idea
of diversifying into other things but
just know it's not just oh it's there
and we sit there and it's fine there's
going to be some work involved when you
have rentals so just just know that on
the front end but pay cash for it don't
go into debt for it yeah I'm just park
it in a high yield savings account for
now when you're ready to pull the
trigger on real estate or invest it go
for it you guys are doing great this is
the ramsy
[Music]
show
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz if
you missed it we've got some fun stuff
happening right now at Ramy
solutions.com of course we have the $12
sale one of our favorite things we do
every year where you get a killer deal
on some of our bestselling books and
products and tools and while you're at
the store you'll see the Ramsey cash
giveaway we're giving away 500 bucks
every week grand prize of
$5,000 and on top of that we've got some
really fun new products in there like
Rachel Cruz's brand new kids book I'm
glad for what I have beautifully
Illustrated a wonderful message for both
parents and kids alike and Rachel's
modeling it like Vanna White holding it
up right now it's so great if you're
watching youge you should like my fourth
child it's so fun just to look at you
know it's a wonderfully illustrated book
we also have the 2024 Ramsey gold
planner a Rachel Cruise wallet Navy as
well as my brand new book The First One
whenever it's called Breaking Free from
broke the Ultimate Guide to more money
and less stress you can check that all
out at ramsy solutions.com
sstore all right let's get to the phones
Kade is in Toledo Kade how's it
going hey guys how are you doing doing
well how can we serve you
today uh yeah so um I have just a quick
question um
involving a budget so my whole life
nobody's ever talked about money or
budget or anything like that it was
always work and shove your money in a
traditional savings account and so my I
work construction and my pay fluctuates
throughout the year so there's some
months where I'm bringing in a lot more
money than like other months like around
the winter time whenever it kind of
slows down um but I get paid on a weekly
basis so I was kind of just wanting to
ask you guys what your opinions are as
far as a good weekly budgeting strategy
I love it well you're here with the
budgeting Queen herself Rachel Cruz so
you're in good hands my friend we're
going to walk you through it so great
Kate okay so the we call it like the
mountain tops and The Valleys throughout
the year knowing that you're in an in in
an industry that you're going to have
great months and not so great months can
you predict those months is it seasonal
like can you look out over a calendar
and say yep I know these months will be
high and these will be low or is it per
project most of the time yes um I would
say 95% of the time yes okay perfect
okay so what I would do Kate is I would
look at the month and we we teach you to
Budget on a monthly basis to look at a
whole picture even though your your pay
may be different you get paid weekly is
that what you said yes okay perfect yeah
so so your paychecks will be coming in
so we'll do some paycheck planning we'll
talk about that in a second but I would
just estimate per month hey here's what
I think I'm going to make in November
here's what I I think I'm going to make
in December and you do it every single
month before the month begins now with
the higher months let's just pretend you
do December next month and it's a high
month so you know okay here's my um here
are my priorities which is going to be
giving it's going to be some saving do
you have any savings right
now uh yes I actually have a high yield
savings account how much is in
that um well I've got about two grand in
there right now 2,000 perfect okay so
you're going to you're done with baby
step one are you do you have any debt
any Consumer
Debt uh yes I'm paying on a car right
now okay how much is how much is left on
it uh about 12,000 12,000 and how much
do you make a
year
um uh I would say it's between about
990,000 and 120,000 so we Med say 100
yep okay perfect okay so what you're
going to do on the budget is you're
going to give first I would skip saving
because you have your emergeny fund
already done your $1,000 then you're
going to go to What's called the four
walls which is food shelter utilities
Transportation make sure those are
covered then you're going to go to your
next kind of necessity so that's going
to be like Insurance um for those of you
listening this may not be UK but like
Child Care maybe one um it's things that
you're like we pretty much need we
really do need these things it's not the
exciting frivolous luxurious stuff yeah
that next kind of group being is like
yeah I really need this stuff paid uh I
would put your minimum I put your car
payment in that one in that section and
then below that Cade you know have like
oh yeah you have a personal line item
maybe a miscellaneous line item a couple
of other things just through life a
subscription or whatever you got going
on yep exactly and so what you're going
to do though is on the high months like
if December's a high month I don't want
you to spend all of that right you're
going to put some of that away and and I
would do a separate account than your
emergency fund I would open up even
another high yield savings and park some
of that money to the side so that's
going to be the fund that you're going
to use when when March hits and it's a
really low month well through December
January February that are high months
you've been putting some money aside to
know that you can grab out of that
account to make sure that all these
things are covered your budget is
covered month to month so it's it's kind
of this game you really do have to play
and it's going to take a second to get
used to um but it's really important and
then what you want to do too is make
sure that when you get paid weekly that
all the bills coming in you can cover
with that paycheck which may mean if a
lot of your bills hit at the first of
the month you may want to call your
utilities or subscriptions or whatever
and say hey can I move this pay date to
the middle of the month or later of the
month so that these other paychecks hit
so you're not overdrafting but that's
called paycheck planning which gets a
little bit more detailed but with every
dollar premium our budgeting app that's
part of the budgeting app every dollar
is this paycheck planning so if you hold
on the line Kade uh I'm going to get you
a free subscription for that for a year
cuz this app is really going to take
kind of what I just said in a two-minute
radio call to really give you the
details and actually see these
categories figure it all out but I would
encourage you 2K that it's not going to
be great the first month you're going to
mess up you're going to over budget in
one category you're going to have to
change some stuff throughout the month
the second month gets a little bit
better but by the third month it really
will start working and so there's some
planning because of your industry and
what you have but it's still very
possible it's still very possible to
budget and I and I love this call
because
this is one of the basic foundational
principles of personal finance that is
so key that allows you to really have
control of your money and actually let
your income work for you and do what you
want it to do beautifully said Kate does
that hit you right yeah thank yes thank
you so much that was perfect that was
everything I needed to hear great and I
want you to pay off that car debt ASAP
yes so in that budget Cade you're not
going to be going out to eat you're not
going to be doing all that you're going
to get all of this paid off this $1,000
car debt paid off as fast as you can and
then save up an emergency fund so you
have some goals that your budget is
there to help you you're able to look at
your budget and say okay I can cut this
category I can cut this category I'm
going to throw all this extra and you
can actually watch it on the app as you
start throwing more money at it watch
that car Deb go down and it's really
motivating that's what get exciting yeah
you're in a great spot but hold on the
line Kate Emily's going to pick up and
we'll give you every dollar premium uh
because it's a great tool it's one
actually I open up every day genuinely
oh yeah and Kade this is a great uh
great time for you to call on Friday
we're going to be walking through how to
use that feature in every dollar so sign
up at every.com budgeting I'm doing a
free training where I show people how to
break the paycheck to paycheck cycle how
to find margin to attack the debt to get
the emergency fund to invest for the
future and part of that we show you what
these premium features in every dollar
do and how to use them and paycheck
planning is one of those so please join
me for that and uh if you're listening
out there and you want to join there's
plenty of virtual spots because it's
virtual so go to everydollar.com
budgeting and we'll send you a link you
can even watch the replay if you miss it
there but Rachel what you just laid out
is really just a prioritized spending
plan for those that have regular income
yeah on commission pay their contract
work whatever it is they need a budget
more than anyone but a lot of them self
they opt out and go Rachel I have a
regular income so this budgeting thing
it doesn't work for me yeah the the
commission people it always is it's and
it is a little bit more tough it'd be
nice to know oh I'm going to make X
every single month every paycheck is
going to be the exact of course it's
going to be easier to plan but if you
are commission again there's some
fluctuation that's happening but it's
still possible and I think budgeting it
is it's one of those uh you know getting
out of debt is a huge financial
principle that's that that changes your
life investing in compound interest is a
principle that you look at and and a way
to save your money that's so helpful
there's all these these like you know
pillars if you will to win financially
and and budgeting is one of those if not
one of the biggest I mean it's it's such
a crucial part of it and when you
actually have control over your income
and know where it's going it goes
further it goes further you get out of
debt faster you save faster you actually
know what's going on versus a paycheck
hitting your account spending some stuff
and looking up and be like gosh I don't
know I don't know where my money is yeah
well you've always said uh budgeting is
permission to spend yes and so I have a
whole chapter in my new book break and
free from broke and the chapter is
called budgeting is freedom that is my
thesis and I show people how to gain
that freedom because it's so true people
look at a budget like a straight jacket
I'm going no no no no it's freedom is
permission to spend on purpose with a
plan so you actually hit your goals
instead of just fingers crossed eyes
closed hope we get there that's the
power of a budget and every dollar is
the best tool out there you can go check
that out if you haven't
[Music]
already
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Rachel Cruz our
scripture of the day comes from Proverbs
1:7 the fear of the Lord is the
beginning of knowledge fools despise
wisdom and instruction and in a left
turn here Taylor Swift once said I think
Fearless is having fears but jumping
anyway beautifully said that I feel like
Rachel planned the Taylor Swift quote
today I didn't y'all always give me
great quotes that feel very inspiring
and uplifting shout out to Don thanks
our friend Don medley love it what a
jewel oh well hey other news the Ramsey
Show annual listener survey is now live
people have been clamoring for this
Rachel they went where is that survey
and it is here we have we have heard
your cries America they said I want my
opinion heard it is so helpful we do
this once a year and here's what we want
to know your favorite parts of the show
what you like what you don't like what
you want to hear more about whatever it
is we want to hear from you and there's
two ways to participate there's
something for the whole family here if
you're a texter just text the word
survey to this number 3378 n we'll send
you a link or you can go to ramsy
solutions.com
SLS survey it's about the same amount of
you know typing but hey to each his own
if you want to go website or text there
you go and if you sign up today you can
be entered to win a $500 gift card just
for taking a few minutes to share your
opinion with us we always want to
continuously improve this show and make
it better yeah and it's so helpful so
please do it it is helpful for us the
the Rachel's plea really hit that it
added some punch to mine so thank you
for that genuinely though we we do this
show for you guys who are listening and
watching so we want to make sure we're
giving you what what you want or we're
just sitting here for 3 hours just
wasting wasting everyone's time that's
fun well hey Stephanie joins us she
makes this show worth doing she's in
Allentown Pennsylvania Stephanie what's
going
on hi I um I have a question regarding
an investment so about two and a half
years ago uh we had sold our house and
and purchased a new house and had some
additional funds that my husband and I
chose to put into an investment account
uh with a financial advisor who is a
fiduciary and um in the course of two
years the account has fluctuated quite a
bit and profited none but we still pay
the
1% um fee to the to the financial
advisor and I'm I'm torn between pulling
all of the money from that account and
just putting it in an S&P 500 investment
account where I don't have that uh you
know that fin cial advising fee and I
wanted your advice how much money are we
talking so it was uh
150,000 and then now it fluctuates
between 130 and 140 it it really has not
gotten to or or surpass 150 okay and
what's it invested in do you know what
types of
funds um some of it is is I think
there's a a small lump sum in cash and
then several accounts that are uh uh
stocks single stocks or mutual
funds um I think both okay well that
could be one reason uh did you choose
these or did the financial advisor say
hey here's what I'm going to put you
into and you went okay sounds good the
financial adviser
does well you know I know you said it's
a fiduciary which I don't think it's one
of our smartvestor Pros we would
recommend mutual funds if you're going
to be investing in that or index funds
in a account like that and so I don't I
Can't Tell You Why the reasons are you
haven't seen the return obviously the
market has been all over the place uh
we've seen it come back nicely but you
know it may take some time to recover
from the year previous and so I want you
to invest with a long-term mindset if
you were trying to allow this money to
grow in two years or else it's bust that
worries me as a from an investing
standpoint but it worries me from you
taking that money and managing on your
own because if the money doesn't grow
next year you're going to go I got to
move it elsewhere I got to move it
elsewhere and the key with investing is
to ride that thing like a roller coaster
until the bidder end uh so that you
don't get hurt jumping off early yeah
well you guys use this money Stephanie
for anything or is this in retirement
like this isn't within your like 401K in
Roth right this is beyond that so
brokerage account yes okay yes this is
beyond that and and I we also so I have
an investment account that I invest in
every month and is in the a mutual fund
and my husband also has another
investment account that he manages uh
which is also in another uh mutual fund
it just seems like this broker managed
fund I think because we are in our early
or mid 30s that it is more aggressive
and and leaning on stock because every
time I look at the portfolio it does
change yeah um it it you know whereas at
least with the stability of the S&P 500
accounts that you know my husband and I
manage you know it I we understand that
there's a longterm gain that we expect
to hopefully have yeah there there's
another piece of this which is financial
advisors don't exist just to help you
choose funds there's so much more value
they can add from Estate Planning and
tax planning strategies um bigger
picture financial decisions and so I
don't want you to ditch a financial
adviser just because the funds they
chose didn't 10 extra money um but and
it feels like you're comfortable
managing some of this on your
own correct yes which is fine the key is
to be thinking longterm now you
mentioned you have a mortgage as
well uh we do what's left on
that um we have about 400,000 on our
mortgage but we have like a
3% uh I think our our we have about 3%
so that tells me you don't you're not in
a rush to pay it off correct correct I
would pay it off just saying are you
guys already maxing out retirement it
sounds like you have a great income
what's your household income
uh yes so I make 180 and then my husband
makes about 120 amazing you make 300
Grand a year I'm guessing you're maxing
out every tax advantage retirement
account
possible yes so we both max out our
retirement uh we both make contributions
to the investment accounts you know the
the one uh hanging fruit that we have is
I have a one car payment but oh
Stephanie yeah we're going that was that
was a question that they said you guys
didn't have time for but that was uh
another question of of do we have do we
bite the bullet take out money from the
investment accounts and pay the car or
you leave the money in the investment
account do you have any money outside of
investment accounts you could use first
we do so we do have um about 16 Grand in
savings and then like immediate like
just cash and then we have the uh
another about 15 grand
in uh like I said go the investment
accounts that I manag and then I got 25
and the one that my husband managed how
much is left on the
car uh
50 I mean I would probably have a dent
into the car yeah I would use some of
this honestly just to get that
completely paid off and then I would and
I would look Stephanie at aggressively
paying off the mortgage I mean you know
your income is there and you guys are
doing great but you're going to be fine
with retirement and all of it I me
you're doing exactly what you need to be
doing and you guys have just extra
margin I would be taking that extra
margin instead of putting it into these
brokerage accounts I would be throwing
it at the house and start getting that
paid off quicker than what you guys are
doing
now okay is there any so I'm sorry no I
was gonna say that yeah that would be
the goal I mean I would I would have
that kind of goal because I feel like
with you guys you guys are in such a
great position you're young you make
amazing money you're going to be
multi-millionaires we're just trying to
give you a real simple peaceful path to
uh to grow that money no I appreciate
that and and I guess do you find that
year-over-year any investment
appreciation like the paying off of of
the mortgage in the car would be better
than potential like appreciation that
would come from
Investments it's all hypothetical you
know it's we don't know what the future
holds and even if my investment would
have been 10% but I paid down to 3% it's
beyond math at that point it's emotional
and um having a paid for house having no
debt to anyone while making 300 Grand
who cares what the spread was going to
be at that point you're going to be
investing so heavily so if I'm in your
shoes let me lay out the game plan real
quick you're in baby steps 456 of the
Ramsay plan invest 15% of your household
income that's 45 Grand that's maxing out
2 401ks pretty much right mhm beyond
that any is going to go to knock out the
house once the house is knocked out
you're in baby step 7 where you can
start maxing out everything would you
casat out a brokerage to pay off the car
if you don't have the money I would Cash
Out The Brokerage it doesn't sound like
you're going to have much capital gains
if at all so uh that would be my plan
Stephanie I appreciate the call and
letting us uh give you our two cents
don't know if it was worth that much to
you but you got it that puts this hour
of the ramsy show in the books my thanks
to my co-host Rachel Cruz all the folks
in the booth and you America thanks for
listening we'll be back before you know
it in the meantime spend wisely save
intentionally and give
[Music]
generously